alors kelly sinon votre couple ex aequo
mon coup de griffe c'est c'est juste
insupportable parce que c'est la
deuxième fois que ça arrive ça arrive en
france pour la deuxième fois là ça se
passe dans les pyrénées c'est encore un
ours
donc c'est une race protéger
mondialement et qui s'est fait abattre
d'une d'une balle voilà donc il y avait
même la ministre de la transition
écologique 1 isabelle borne à tweeté l a
dit l ours a été découvert aujourd'hui
en ariège abattu par balles l'ours est
une espèce protégée cet acte est
illégale et profondément condamnable la
préfète s'est rendu sur place l'aide à
l'état va porter plainte a sauvegardé
petit résumé de la sphère des tiers dans
l'ariège que des témoins ont découvert
stupéfaits le cadavre d'un ours tués par
des braconniers tout de suite elisabeth
borde la ministre de la transition
écologique a tenu à réagir
un ours a été découvert aujourd'hui en
ariège abattu par balles
l'ours est une espèce protégée cet acte
est illégale et profondément condamnable
la préfète s'est rendu sur place
l'état va porter plainte de leur côté
les responsables de l'association le
pays des sources ont expliqué qu'ils
n'avaient pas l'intention de laisser ces
actes impunis
nous allons bien sûr porté plainte et
tout faire pour que cet axe d'une part
condamné d'autre part préparer comme il
le rappelle la loi impose que chaque
course a battu par la main de l'homme
soient immédiatement remplacé pour
éviter de donner raison aux braconniers
aujourd'hui en france il ne reste que 50
ours un chiffre très faible qui pourtant
un record depuis des décennies
[Musique]
oui bonsoir bernard que vous travaillez
sur la chaîne animaux
oui c'est pour ça j'aimerais que je la
regarde tout le temps ces gentilles à
une émission que j'adore avec un
vétérinaire un beau gosse un blond comme
ça qui va dans tous les pays et j'adore
on regarde ça et je vous dit j'adore les
enfants adorent
elle est très sympa cette chambre est
très sympa puis elle vous paye bien m me
pécresse démission aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs mise à part cela non les ours
est un vrai problème parce qu' on essaie
une nouvelle version des ours dans les
pyrénées wire ou en ariège et c'est
parce que c'est nécessaire sauf que ce
qui est vrai aussi c'est ce sont les
bergers les bergers tulle et les
troupeaux donc il ya vraiment un
un équilibre à trouver entre toutes ces
personnes je suis un grand défenseur des
animaux tueur mais je reconnais que les
ours et baï boustouler tout bon ben si
tu lisais un manque de communication
dans tous les cas parce que là bas dit
je sais qu'un jour ça oui on peut se
parler dominique vien prenable à la
maison et on peut se parler il ya deux
organisations qui se confrontent il ya
ceux qui vont les introduire celles qui
veulent les exclure mais ça fait
s'affaisser cesser ces nuisibles pour
les animaux en eux mêmes et ils n'ont
pas mérité ils ont rien demandé
ils sont protégés donc dans tous les cas
c'est illégal voilà ménager la chèvre et
le chou